i think that one of the reasons that
people have
less faith in
experts now is because the experts have
essentially been ignoring the conspiracy
theories and just censoring them
and when you do that that makes people
think right you don't have an answer to
this
but you are a tyrant
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant and returning guest
today is a youtuber and the founder of
lotusetus.com
carl benjamin sargon of a cat as you're
formerly known welcome to back to
trigonometry thanks so much for having
me back it's a much nicer studio than
the previous thank you very much lovely
honestly uh not not least in part to
guests like you who were willing to come
on it when it wasn't a very nice studio
and you know one of the things that
i always really liked about our
conversations is i think when you first
came on the show we probably didn't
agree on very much i think we've
probably moved somewhat uh since uh
towards some of the views that you had
or maybe we unearthed some of the views
we already had over time
but one of the things i always really
appreciated about you is your
willingness to engage with people in
conversation who who have different
opinions oh i i mean i think that a lot
of disagreement is merely about framing
right so it seems that if you just learn
how to frame things in uh just you know
just literally turn the situation around
and just frame it a different way you
find people actually things just
slotting this place actually no that is
that is something sensible right um and
so without conversation you can't do
that and so and this is one of the
things that makes your show great is
that you have such a wide variety of
people with such radically different
views and yet you know you always go
away from those conversations with
something interesting
well speaking of conversations the last
time we spoke was ex we're recording
this on january the 6th
2022.
uh the last time we spoke was i think uh
january the 6th 2021. how's it been
january
after you had us on your show that's
right and i think we may have not framed
things correctly because your audience
really struggled with our moderate point
of view well
it's it's about the paradigms you come
from i think
because
like
i'm not happy with the sort of
mainstream westminster paradigm that
seems to have been you know sort of the
blair rights paradigm that the but the
all parties seem to be trapped within
what do you mean by that paradigm
explain that yeah this sort of um
administrative managerial paradigm that
sits there and and looks at the world
and says right okay i need to impose a
speech code in this way so someone can't
offend someone else and things like this
i i think the matter of matters of
defense aren't actually anything to do
with the state i think they're to do
with the individuals involved because
it's also subjective and nothing can be
really properly proven that it me it's
something that you know people should be
negotiating for for themselves but the
managerial state looks at that and goes
right there might be harm involved in
this i need to impose a law i need to
impose bureaucrats i need to impose
people who will sit there and start
getting involved in the relationships
between people and it's that kind of
paradigm where it's the sort of
overarching um
i don't think like big government
because it sounds cliche but the scope
of the state is in everything now and
this i think we see
reaching its full
the of full blossoming in the covid
crisis where literally there is nothing
outside of the purview of the state now
and i've i'm genuinely
worried about where this paradigm is
going because i mean i don't see
anything good at the end of it and i
can't see who's happy with the way
things are being run at the moment
it's a great point for example you look
at what's happened to civil liberties
right the way through this crisis
they're in the toilet and everyone was
kind of went yeah we don't need them
anymore why do you need the ability to
protest what good came of that well as
your friend uh or former friend i don't
know put it why do you need free speech
in a pandemic yeah
what kind of question is you know
why do you need your inalienable rights
yeah well i mean because they're a part
of me you know and if you take that away
then you're taking a part of me away you
know but this this is the problem that
the the administrative state looks at
rights as things that are constructed by
the state and therefore can just be
taken away by the state at any given
time for any given reason and that
really concerns me because that's not
like
the english view of rights you know the
english view of rice is that these are
ancient and hereditary i mean you can
look back through any piece of like
english constitutional legislation and
you'll find the phrase ancient liberties
and customs and it's really weird like
edinburgh like essentially came to the
conclusion that the english are dull
sluggish people who have never innovated
anything and because they've always
assumed to have everything they needed
like going back to like sacks and times
in the woods you know and this this sort
of inherited ideal i mean at least
is tied to something you know it's at
least tied something you know we've got
a thousand five hundred years of english
liberty okay great now we've got like
human rights okay what's that tethered
to you know what guarantees that i will
have the same human rights tomorrow that
i had today or the day after i won't
have any human rights at all you know
it's it's all bound up in the the whims
of the people who are running the state
and i i really hate this paradigm you
know and and tony blair has sort of like
snuck it in
and reformed our country and the
conservatives
are just sat with it and are essentially
now being buffeted around by the labour
party on every issue and it was through
the pandemic it was the most
insufferable thing wasn't it boris
johnson was you know the the instinctive
sort of the englishman like we're not
going to do that we're not going to do
that and then kirsten would say we have
to lock down and then 24 hours later
boris jones said there's going to be a
lockdown it's like well there we go the
creature of the labour party because
you're within their paradigm and so the
logic of the paradigm dictates that
that's what you have to do at any given
stage and but again like
you know who put us here you know nobody
asked for this and how do we escape it
that's the question and it that's the
worrying point in that there doesn't
seem to be any escape where you look
through the
the journey that we've had through the
lockdowns the vaccine passports
introduced in scotland and wales they're
now going to introduce them here and you
think
i didn't sign up for any of this and not
only did i not sign up for any of this
it doesn't [ __ ] work
so why are you introducing it can you
imagine what william wallace thinks of
the snp
can you even imagine like the word
freedom is just a joke and i mean
it's it's mad watching it isn't it like
in wales you can go to the pub but you
can't go to work
it's like sorry whose idea of health
care is that the welshman
exactly but that's because it's not tied
to anything is it you know it's like the
the whims of this arbitrary state that
just lurch from crisis to crisis and
make up rules off the top of the head
because now they have absolute power you
know now they have nothing that
restrains them from just being like
right well we can do that we're gonna do
that we're gonna do that and so end up
with this wild contradictory like root
through the past like six months and it
feels like you've been doing it for 20
years you know it feels like like just
so much time has passed when it's it's
been one year you know
or two years and it's like right okay
this has got to stop you know we need to
get some sort of constancy some sort of
level-headedness the government has to
understand that there are limits on it
you know it can't just say right all
your business is shut down apart from
you know amazon tesco sainsbury's small
businessman too bad you know you're all
locked
this has got to stop you know so carl
it's interesting what you're talking
about that it seems to me is that we
seem to have got to a place where if
there's a problem the government is
supposed to fix it and we've forgotten
that some problems can't be fixed some
problems can't be fixed by government
and also a lot of the solutions to
problems have trade-offs so yes you can
solve this problem but you're going to
hurt a lot of people over here or take
away certain freedoms and if you embrace
that fully particularly in the pandemic
when there's fear people are dying etc
and you don't have those uh checks and
balances of inalienable rights things
that can never be taken away from you
then you end up in the sort of austrian
german position where it's like well
these people these people will stay at
home and pay a fine and it's like why
but when did the government have the
authority to put people in their homes
and never let them out because they
haven't followed government advice and
we're already seeing that we're only
seeing that in france in austria where
on the unvaccinated as if that's a
constituency you know as if there's
anything that connects them other than
they haven't
had a particular injection you
mispronounce it you're missing
that's how you do it i i think more
colloquially they're just called the
jews
are being targeted by the state because
they're not obeying the commands of the
administration administrative class
that's commanding everything that's
going on and and
no notice how you i you're exactly right
about the trade-offs because th this
there was a in the 20th century there's
a british philosopher called michael
oakshott who pointed out that this kind
of administrative form of doing politics
reduces time to being into the now you
know and it's always now and so that
turns politics into the politics of a
felt need so whatever is immediately in
front of us oh we have to do something
and because essentially nothing is out
of
the scope of the state that means we can
do everything right now and so right
lock down right now it's like okay
that's fine the nhs didn't get
overwhelmed brilliant but is that worth
tens of thousands of cancer patients who
are now going to die of cancer you know
that seems to be what's you know
is being revealed from the lockdowns and
so this is one of the trade-offs that
you were saying it's like okay well
if we'd taken a slightly longer view of
the the proceedings and actually been
concerned about what was going to happen
in a year's time we would have said well
we can guarantee that tens of thousand
people will die of preventable diseases
that are possibly preventable that could
have been treated now but you know we
were just worried that the nhs would be
over well the argument would have been
from those people is if the nhs had got
overwhelmed the cancer patients would
have died and also loads of people would
have died of covet and other things too
possibly yeah possibly but we don't
really know the answer to that exactly
and look at the predictions i mean we're
sitting here in early january we were
told that if no restrictions are imposed
in this country in december there would
be six thousand deaths i think there was
four hundred well this this week this
this leads on to another another point
shot make actually about the the the
models and the theories and how they
match up to the practical reality that
we're actually living because i mean
look at look at the sage modeling the
sage modeling you can find the graphs
online they're just so wildly wrong you
know they're so catastrophically and
embarrassingly wrong
you may as well go to predictions from
mystic meg you know the these are
literally you know russell grant
predictions uh more accurate than these
models and yet you know these people are
still informing government policy and so
you end up in a position where theory
just does not match the reality it's
okay so what are we doing you know we're
sat in this
we are misinformed by the people who are
considered the only legitimate
authorities and i mean i'm not saying i
have any authority to inform anyone
about anything either you know i don't
know anything about code i don't know
anything about you know any of the the
problems that we're having really other
than what we can commonly see but we can
see that like a bit of prudence you know
sure it's scary and the felt need is oh
god you know the nhs is going to be
overwhelmed
so be it you know that so be it you know
that's not a justification to tyrannize
our entire society i didn't sign up to
the glory of the nhs you know the nhs is
meant to serve us you know if the nhs
you know has problems then we do our
best and muddle through them you know
which has always been the the
traditional way that we do and maybe
also it needs more funding i'm open to
that possibility well it's a black hole
of funding anyway it is but but also i i
think the problem is capacity and it's
not just at the moment it's been that
way for for decades uh every winter
there's a crisis well maybe we need to
find some way of not having a crisis
every winter right i agree i agree no no
i totally agree and i mean
another problem that we that ties into
this is numbers it's immigration you
know during 2020 when we're having all
the lockdowns 700 000 people came to
live in this country
but how did that happen in the middle of
a pandemic you know when we're all
confined to our homes and why would 700
000 people come to a country that's
locked down you know and yet this still
happened and so the these are you know
people who can get sick from covid and
then end up in a hospital that they've
in a country they've just arrived in you
know so they've contributed nothing to
the system the system is not prepared
for these extra numbers and so we end up
again in crisis after crisis after
crisis with no end in sight and it's the
paradigm that we're in that's creating
the problems and it's like okay well i
mean what's the solution you know but
there is no solution and the problem as
well is the government's attitude which
what you're talking about which is a
reactive one it's not a proactive it's
completely reactive
the thing that i find worrying as well
is that it encourages a passivity in
people yeah they're very passive and
they it's not anymore about you know so
solving your problems thinking about how
you're going to improve your life you
look to government to solve it and once
that happens
we're in a really really dark place
because people give up agency well
you're not really free are you yeah
that's the problem and wha what's worse
is that you've given up your agency to
an institution that is not capable of
looking out for your future because
they're too busy panicking about the
problem of the day and so
okay this is going to end badly isn't it
it feels like a car that's about to
crash
every day it feels like we're in a car
that's about to crash and so
the problem i think is that the
government
do know what to do they are just
essentially so hen-pecked by the the the
people who support the blairite paradigm
that they feel they can't step outside
of it which is very bizarre because i
think a lot of people in this country do
want to step outside of this paradigm i
mean for example the government could
just say well look we're just going to
have to reduce the number of people who
come here you know this is just one of
those things if we want to save the nhs
this is an inevitable thing or we
continue to just pour money down the
black hole
that might not even be a success you
know we're assuming that just simply
more money more money is going to solve
the problem whereas in fact it's just
the numbers of people trying to access
this service that's you know
overwhelming it and so okay well that's
one thing they could do but you know
that tomorrow if they came out and said
look we're just going to for the next
five years just refuse visas you know
you could i'm sure they've got a website
where it's like apply for your visa here
and if they just took that down and said
sorry we're not receiving applications
for visas at the moment nobody's human
rights are violated nobody gets hurt
nothing changes nobody's you know
nothing wrong happens except that would
be advantageous to the country and the
nhs i think it's probably a little bit
extreme in the sense that that would
actually you know there are some people
who are coming into the country who need
to come into the country the benefits
this country as well hang on a second
like this is one of those trade-offs
though because yeah sure there are there
are going to be like you know gdp
benefits and things like that no no
that's not what i mean i mean there are
people who are coming here to to be
top-level doctors who are going to work
in the nhs what i'm saying is i i'm not
saying reducing immigration is not a
worthy goal i think it has been too high
since the blair period i i always when
people say who's responsible for brexit
quote-unquote i say tony blair he made
it right but what what i think in my
opinion you need which is actually the
brexit argument ironically which i voted
remain in is you need an immigration
system that is
that is calibrated to the needs of the
host country that means you get to
choose how many people come what their
skills are what they're going to do here
etc and then you can have the number of
people that you need to come in and do
the things that you want them to do that
you allow them to do rather than just
saying we're not letting anyone in well
i mean i'm honestly i'm of the opinion
now that maybe a zero in policy is
actually what we need um because it's
not just the material needs of the
country that are at issue here there
there are genuine social problems
there's a widespread i think problem of
alienation
and i think the next census is going to
show us just how deeply that's going to
cut
um what do you mean by it in nation car
as in the english people thinking
they're no longer at home in england
because you can look at cities like
birmingham where in
we're waiting for this latest census but
i found the cat the birmingham council's
data on children in their schools and
they happen to have an ethnic breakdown
of children in their schools and only a
third of them were english
and so now you've got london and
birmingham which are the two largest
cities in england that are majority
non-english
and i'm not saying that there's anything
wrong with immigrants or anything like
that but i am saying it's a bit of a
strange state of affairs when that's the
case and if i went to other countries
and found if i went to nigeria and found
that nigeria's major cities were
populated with chinese people
i would wonder why they probably will be
to be fair
no they'll just be the ones running it
i i that's the thing i i i would
understand that the nigerians would feel
a sense of alienation from their own
civilization but but what i'm saying to
you carl and this is why i'm pushing
back on you is i understand that concern
i do understand that concern and uh it's
uncomfortable for people to hear but i i
understand the concern what i'm saying
though is i think the reaction i to me
reducing immigration to zero would be an
overreaction the trade-offs of which
would hurt this country well what do you
think the trade-offs would be uh first
of all a lot of people who come here on
visas come here for only a few months to
do a particular job people from abroad
to come and you know do a trade
delegation or whatever all that sort of
thing uh there are also people who come
here and contribute start businesses as
i have etc and i would like to think my
contribution as an immigrant to this
country is not only in the taxes that
i've paid
and so there are people who will come
and contribute they will come and invent
things they will come and create things
that will be huge benefits um and so to
lose if you had an immigration look when
i came to this country in 1995
three percent of the british public
thought that immigration was a major
issue three percent why because
immigration was about 30 or 40 000
people a year that was manageable that
people could integrate people could
learn the language people could fit in
people didn't end up in a ghetto of
their own community
uh what we've seen
is that when you have levels of
immigration like we've had since
hundreds of thousands every year that
has a detrimental effect so to me it's
about scale uh and i'm wary of that the
overreaction uh of the that what we need
is to just go okay that's it i think
there are some there's some trade-offs
at that extreme end that are not going
to be good for this country
i don't really see
why
this is a major concern though right i'm
not i'm not suggesting that we should
remove anyone who's here or anything
like that
obviously you know and and i i totally
no actually i i totally wouldn't
obviously um because
wouldn't you no absolutely not you would
yeah i would i i think that there's
extra strength in the immigrant who is
also the patriot right i mean you see
this like eric zamorin in france at the
moment he's his family are algerian jews
and he is the most patriotic of the
current candidates for the presidency of
france and arguing most strongly from
like traditional french perspectives uh
from them in order to make his points
because he's
he he obviously loves the country right
and you you obviously
really love the place no but but we
don't want to deport or not deport
people based on their beliefs right so
you don't want to deport anyone no no i
don't want to put anyone and i i
wouldn't want the state to become
intrusive like that one of the one of
the main problems i have with the kovid
problems is that the state has become
unbelievably intrusive and i can't stand
the idea of the state being intrusive
but there are just normal bureaucratic
things that we can do we can just have a
five-year moratorium on immigration as
in would just say sorry we're not giving
out visas because i mean we've we've
literally had
tens of millions of immigrants come into
the country and i mean even in small
tens of millions yeah when in what
period uh since 1997.
we've had tens of millions are you sure
yeah i think it's probably in the i
think it's about 15 million something
like that now
since 1997 yeah
it's a huge i mean we had seven hundred
thousand last year
you know it's it's a it's a talking show
or or
the population of this country is not
increased by anything like that in this
time well i don't know
we we actually don't know i mean like
sainsbury's thought that we were feeding
80 million people um because we don't
know about you know illegal immigration
obviously and in the in 2011 it was
something like 68 million but i'm i'm
sure it's going to be probably around 75
million now uh there it's just been a
huge number of people you know and so
it's like right we i mean even if i'm
overestimating it it's still one of
those things that you can see
like i walk around my town of swindon
now
and i can see that it's different
like after after christmas i went to the
local shopping center and i swear to god
half of the people in there were foreign
and not native like native born people
from somewhere you know from a foreign
descent but people with strange accents
speaking strange languages and i was
feeling this sense of alienation that i
hear about from lots of people around
the country and so it i'm not you know
we don't need to do anything
other than just say well look we can
just for five years refuse visas we
don't need to give visas to foreigners
um we can i think surmount the problems
that you're bringing up
from within i don't think that we have
to look elsewhere and i'm actually a bit
wary of the well why don't we get
doctors from some other country because
it feels
it feels like an inversion of the sort
of colonial argument
where it's like well we'll we'll just
take their resources because that indian
doctor who was born and raised in india
trained in india was born and raised and
trained on indian resources resources i
don't think we have a right to yeah and
then so if we're like yeah but we can
pay you three times more than you can
get in india
he's naturally inclined to come over and
so that's essentially us taking a good
doctor from india where i'm sure they
need good doctors in india no that's a
good argument and i'm sure that we can
train it's a good argument the the thing
i would disagree with you very strongly
and just give you a personal example is
you said no one gets hurt well that's
not true if you don't allow people to
come for example my wife is about we're
about to have our first child right my
my in-laws might want to come and see
their grandson uh my my family might
want to come in i'm not saying people
can't visit right i mean
no visas yeah but uh a residential visa
we don't give citizenship oh right okay
so basically you can come and visit i
said yeah
arguing about something based on a
misunderstanding i didn't wonder why you
were quite sorry yeah i was like yeah i
would not allow anyone to come in really
no i'm not thinking about building what
you're saying is you you don't want
anyone coming here for permanent
settlement yes okay sorry i i should
have been yeah
and when you say visas
sorry yeah
yeah yeah i should have been more clear
okay great you've just wasted 15 minutes
of your time listening to people argue
about something that they actually
misunderstood yeah sorry about that
because like we've got a genuine housing
crisis as well at the moment i mean and
all of the problems that we're having
honestly seem to stem from just an
excess number of people
but there's also a large part of the
housing crisis called is corruption and
it's corruption in the housing industry
it's the fact that the you know
council as well with companies
you know they what they do is a drip
drip drip of building houses because
that way you can sell them for far more
money nobody's doing anything about it
and
well i mean another another problem is
allowing uh non-british people uh and
and companies you know agents uh to
purchase land in britain i mean why are
russian oligarchs able to buy up tracks
of london why are saudi oil
given right to buy property exactly
right and before thatcher and reagan it
just wasn't allowed you know you just
don't allow foreigners to buy up your
country and it's like the swiss don't
allow it and why should they you know
what it's this it's very much a
neo-liberal way of thinking and i'm not
a neo-liberal so i'm just like okay well
then why would i allow that and i you
know i would totally understand any
country saying well look like this is
one of the things that uh predatory
capitalism does this is what uh chiquita
did in guatemala they basically bought
up half the country and it's like okay
well now they were called the octopus
because they owned everything they had
their tentacles and everything and you
know you've got to you've got to take a
a more broad and deep view of what's
going on and so i'm not you know
there are
there are things that we should be doing
that we're not doing and they they
exacerbate the problems that we're
having and it's outside of the blairite
sort of neoliberal paradigm that the
solutions are found and yet the media
the activists and all of the parties are
essentially trapped within this paradigm
and
nobody seems to be willing to be like
okay well we could just stop giving out
citizenship you know we this is you know
people can still come to this obviously
but you know we we we don't have to
allow 700 000 people here to become
citizens it doesn't have to be the case
and so that saves us a lot of trouble
you know in the future and we we know
that this isn't um
something that
is um
let me from the
we we also know that a lot of people
leave right and so if the problem is
well too many people have come in the
infrastructure is under too much
pressure well there are people who are
just here temporarily you know they only
come to a temporary and then they
personally leave if we're not allowing
loads and more people in then the
problem solves itself in effect you know
and you don't have to do anything you
know you don't have to be invasive you
know because the last thing i want is an
invasive state but there has to be a
solution to these problems
hi francis do you have your own business
no what do you think trigonometry is an
opportunity for me to annoy people and
shout catch phrases birds love it one
two three four five six seven eight nine
ten
well if you do run your own company
you'll know how important branding is to
have a successful business that's why
you should work with the older files
every project is carefully considered
and tailored to ensure your brand is
consistent and memorable to everyone it
reaches most big city agencies are going
to cost you an arm and a leg just so
they can pay their overhead costs the
older files work remotely so you don't
have to worry about being overcharged
not only that they're a one-stop shop
for all your branding needs including
brand development online ad design email
design web design print design motion
graphics and more they do design guys
visit the aldefiles.com forward slash
triggered and fill out the project
request form to get 10 off your first
project and a free consultation that's
the order files dot com slash triggered
and get 10 off your first project and
free consultation
where i'm with you is
i personally are in favor of the swiss
model i don't understand why people from
abroad companies from abroad can come in
by huge waves of london
and just and that is deemed to be fine
and then
the government does nothing to solve the
housing crisis on a multitude of
different levels and we it's just
worsened and it's just deepened so i am
with you on that well one one one
interesting thing i learned the other
day is that 30 percent of the
conservative party's funding comes from
housing developers yeah which is why
there's so many new builds and i see
this all all around the west country
where i live is constantly oh well
they're going to be you know a thousand
new houses built there but that's that's
our countryside that we're building over
to house foreigners you know i'm sorry i
i don't really want to really do it it's
not just the house foreigners though is
it called it's the house is the house
well yeah the british population isn't
growing like we've got a sub-replacement
rate population something like 1.6 i
think is our population replacement rate
so if we had no immigration then we
would have uh decreasing housing prices
because there'd be houses that were just
available because there wouldn't be
enough people to fill them so the the
the fact that we have 700 000 people
come here a year is why we have such a
problem with houses
and but it's also as well the fact that
we also have an aging population so sure
and we do need younger people to come in
to do the work et cetera et cetera
you're smiling
because
doesn't that feel a bit vampiric
we need to steal your youth to look
after our old people i mean it's not the
worst thing we do let's be honest it's
not
but it it's again it's got it's got that
kind of
imperial vibe about it right as in we're
not we're not doing what we should be
doing to maintain ourselves we're
looking at other people who are doing
that thing and we're like yeah we we
just have the money and the resource and
the prestige to to steal your thing and
it's like is that right and then what
happened the thing is but i can't push
back on you is it stealing is it really
stealing kind of thing
are you just offering someone an
opportunity yeah but you are better than
their life yeah but you are leveraging a
superior position over their position
right but but then the question is what
stops them from just following in our
footsteps you know what stops them well
they do ukrainians go to poland to work
and polish people come here but the
problem with the problem with the
demographic issue is that when we're not
having enough children
because we're enjoying our material
comforts too much but what stops them
from doing the same thing because they
might you know they come here they work
for a few years they become prosperous
they're like yeah no i'm gonna just
follow the same example and so
you know they are like well now i need
to like get you know now we need to get
someone else's children to come over and
look after me as an old people as an old
person you know and so it doesn't solve
the problem it actually turns us into a
bit of a sort of black hole of lineages
you know where it's like this is where
this is the the where your grandchildren
come not to have grandchildren but isn't
it
is this right you know is this what we
want for our civilization like and i'm
really glad we're having this
conversation because it's something that
you would never see on any mainstream
platform really especially done to this
detail but isn't what you're really
talking about carl the problems of
globalization
i think the problems are the problems of
the enlightenment
actually as a
philosophical movement
um the the problem is every standard is
a material standard um none of the
standards are something immaterial um
for example like happiness has been
equated with material pleasure right so
you know and physical pleasure as well
well that's what i mean physical
pleasure you know happiness is equated
with taking drugs playing a video game
you know drinking
you know whatever it is sex sex very
much well done yeah
i forgot that
but it's not equation you have been
married for a long time
um but it's not being equated with the
general sense of well-being you have of
being satisfied with your life
and who can say that they've got that
you know how many young people today are
looking at the world and being like yeah
i'm quite satisfied on the path i'm on
they're all depressed you know look at
drug depression drug taking things like
this like
we are we are we are creating a world
for ourselves that we're becoming deeply
unhappy in and we don't understand why
we're deeply unhappy and we're going
increasingly more atomized addicted to
our phones and we we we're building a
trap a prism for ourselves in which
we're going to just keep killing
ourselves frankly because i mean you
look at the suicide rates and it's just
like right okay we need to reassess what
it is to be a human being and i think
the enlightenment paradigm of just
having a materialistic frame
is not sufficient you know this is like
the incompleteness of this paradigm and
so i'm not saying that it's bad it's
been wonderful to do as francis bacon
wanted and to relieve man's estate
because it used to be really bad you
know but now i mean i can't even imagine
i went i went to a a victorian hospital
in london with my wife because she's
fascinated with all this stuff and they
were telling us about how they didn't
have uh you know antiseptic and um
painkillers and things like that and so
you know they here's some whiskey hold
him down boys and then we'll get that
leg off or something it's like oh my god
so
everything that's happened great but
that was 150 years ago and now we're at
at a point where
we're trying to solve problems that we
ourselves have created you know these
aren't problems that we've inherited
from nature and the fact that we you
know we get pain and infections and
things now we've created a world for
ourselves that is making us depressed
and so it's like right okay we need to
we need to look into this and i actually
think that ties into the demographic
problem we've we've
totally devalued the institution of
marriage and parenthood and there's a
lot of human meaning in it you know like
it's it's i'm i'm very happy with my
life because i have children because i'm
married because every day i come home
from work and my boy is like daddy he
comes over and gives me a big hug my my
one year old you can he sits there
bouncing up and down with his little fat
cheeks bouncing and he's thrilled to see
me and honestly i
would
be so terribly depressed if this wasn't
my life you know okay so isn't the
problem carl and i'm going to be go very
left wing here
isn't it capitalism the problem what
you're talking about
this excessive consumption the idea that
the acquirement of material goods
material possession
will lead to happiness when the reality
is we all know that that
happiness is not found in that
particular place i would just pick up
one point there the thing is i think
you're absolutely right but i don't
think we all know that i think actually
most of us are brainwashed into not
acknowledging that fact i think that um
any
anything that follows from capitalism
arrives at that same point uh look at
look at what the communist ideal is
meant to be it's meant to be a point at
which nobody wants for anything you know
and so everyone has everything that
they'll ever want at all times which
means uh a bunch of sort of bug men sat
in the metaverse you know constantly
consuming their soma and eating their
bug burgers and things like that you
know well they're just you know like the
the fat people from wall-e you know
where that's that's where the communists
are going to take us with super
abundance okay
but that's not virtuous isn't it you
know they're not good and virtuous and
happy people they're just people who are
constantly enjoying or suffering from
chemical pleasures in the head and it's
like that's that's not what a human
being should be that's not a good
outcome and so capitalism is doing that
but any any other sort of post and you
know enlightenment system like you know
socialism communism will aim for that as
well and that the problem is aiming for
that is actually i think unhealthy for
us and
we should just change directions okay
why why why can't we
aim more for wholesome communities you
know where because i mean you get
country countries like poland that start
introducing pro-family policies and if
you get that 50 years it's unthinkable
that we'd have anything other than a
pro-family policy because families are
the bedrock of what a civilization is
they're what
can maintains the continuum through time
for producing new generations and we've
severed that you know we've been like oh
well we need we need to focus
excessively on the margins you know we
need to focus successfully on those sort
of you know the the the activists and
the you know gay rights activists things
like this it's like okay but
what are they doing for the future you
know so they're not producing succeeding
generations and so
you know why are they given focus you
know it's interesting that you make this
point carl because with my wife being
pregnant now
thank you and we've obviously put it off
until fair fairly late later in life
but
as that process goes on
i think about this stuff more and more
and and i and i you know the people that
i know mostly or a lot are comedians in
london who live four to a flat and uh
mostly they're not really coping with
life and then they're not really they're
not my chill
i think francis is kind of across a lot
of this stuff really and he's always
been thinking about it quite deeply but
a lot of people young people now in
society live these lives where
as you say it's material pleasures it's
you know going out getting drunk going
to a show and these are all great things
by the way having a drink with your
mates and going to they're all great but
they don't nourish you from within they
don't give you that deep satisfaction
and
we somehow got to a position like i get
this like cringe when you mention pro
family because i think poland hungary
these like
you know these super like uh you know i
don't i don't even know what the right
word is i know what you mean you know
what i mean it's it's it's weird and
old-fashioned and
uncool and not
it's not
uh how to put it like
it's not going to set the world on fire
no right it's not exciting no it's not
it's not progress you know like yeah
yeah yeah
it's not progress yeah um but it is it
is wholesome and it does make people you
know appreciate their position in the
world rather than constantly being depre
i'm you know posting on twitter i'm
depressed i'm depressed okay we'll take
some more medication i guess you know
what what are your options here you know
right and yeah because you're not living
a life that that produces something else
yeah and you can't not be that way if
all you do is go on twitter and go out
and get drunk and whatever you are the
the accumulation of your habits you
think a lot of the things that you do
it's very interesting so you talk about
the enlightenment the reason
it's interesting to me is because there
are cultures that do this differently
right japan for example i have a friend
who i went to school with he's of korean
descent third
generation living in japan his
grandfather came to japan from korea
made a business made a life was very
successful could afford to send their
whole all their kids to an english
boarding school they're not japanese
they haven't got japanese passports you
know their japan made a very clear
decision that they want to keep their
country the way that it is
and
there are
you know you can take whatever view of
that that you want maybe you think
that's racist or wrong or whatever but
but this is what i'm getting at is why
is it that here in the west
we are deeply uncomfortable with the
idea of preserving what you have maybe
to the exclusion of others
is it colonialism is it our history that
you sort of well we came over there and
now you're allowed to come over here is
it that like what is it
i mean i think it's probably a
combination of all of those things but i
think that at base
it begins and ends with enlightenment
philosophy i think it the the the
enlightenment
has a constituency
holds rational thought to be the
key component of any
decision-making process and it's like
sure but actually in reality most of our
decisions are not made through
reflection most of them are habitual you
know i got up i went to the cupboard i
called myself a bowl of cereal and i
didn't think about it at all i just did
it every day i do it and you know but
there's a good reason cause i'm hungry
you know i need to get my breakfast and
so
this this constituency of of rational
agents
is universal because every human is a
rational agent and so the it becomes so
outward looking that it is essentially
demands an imperial perspective where
now i've claimed all of humanity as
being part of my constituency but
they're not you know there are people
all around the world who don't agree
with the way that we do things and don't
want to be part of us and yet we're
laying claim to them anyway so you can
think right your hours it's like well
hang on a second that's a bit arrogant
isn't it you know i mean that's a bit
presumptuous um and we could look at it
through um
what i suppose we'll just call the
traditional lens for now which is the
the continuum of our civilization and
the accumulation of any sort of
inherited wisdom through time and
suddenly you get a much more like
parochial um and particular perspective
you think okay well actually it's not my
job to solve problems all around the
world it's my job to make sure that my
kids have got a safe environment to live
in and go to school and get enough to
eat and you know i'm kind to my
neighbors and suddenly and so it's a
much more sort of relational world
you've got to have a direct relationship
in some way and it might just be like
you know i'm in a country with scottish
people in the highlands but if if
something were to go terribly wrong in
scotland i would contribute to the
charity fund you know because i view
them as my countrymen because that's
what we are whereas sorry if something
happens you know in the jungles of south
america
well it's not really my problem you know
and you know
i know that they have people down there
who are close to them who have relations
with them who will help them out you
know and i assume the goodness of human
nature uh that that will be the case and
at the end of the day ultimately if
something were to happen that you know
desperately needed help i'm not above or
against helping them or anything like
that i'm just saying like
it's the it's the charity but begins at
home mentality you know your affections
begin with those things closest to you
and radiate outwards rather than
abstracting to
everything at all times you know and and
it's this this rationalistic view
of the world that's very thin and
totally universal and also can only
recognize that which is common to
mankind right and this is this is
exactly this is what scrutiny pointed
out about the europeans they went around
the world and they're like wow look
men everywhere have common things about
them you know they're all they'll eat
they all have you know
i was going to say two sexes but um
not anymore dare i say that but they've
all got they've got there's a string
that unites all of humanity in these
commonalities but to do that you have to
abstract away from those things that
make them different and those things
that make us different are the inherited
traditions that we've had the unthinking
but reflected in us you know and francis
you're you're a great example of this
actually right you know you you're an
englishman you know you've got
particular cultural traits you've got
values you've got beliefs the
constantine as a russian doesn't have
but yeah i mean i'm not saying you can't
be friends or anything
but the point is that there are
differences between you both recognize
you know yes respect for the differences
yeah it's absolutely true it's
absolutely true and so and these
differences are particular you know and
and so
it's it's that view of the differences
being important rather than the
universal nature of mankind being the
only thing that's important that i think
is the the bifurcation and and we've
arrived at the universal
managerial state that just doesn't
recognize that there are these
accumulated cultural habits
and it's destroying them you know it
doesn't recognize that it's destroying
them as it allows hundreds of thousands
of people to come here as it legislates
from an ivory tower over the norms of
our local civilizations you know and
and i i can't remember where i was going
well i think like this is what i think
the problem is no no that makes sense i
think the the thing that strikes me
about what you're saying is
and i i i can
chart this because in some ways it
charts my the changes of my thinking as
maybe i've got olders maybe as we've
done the show i talked to different
people but
i think there was some kind of point
where we suddenly decided the progress
was the only value
that we should have
and the entirety of our existence is
about
unshackling ourselves from the the
former traditions which which of course
they were
more sexist and more racist and more
this and more that than than what we are
now and so our job is not to live lives
of meaning and purpose and and to do
things and yes to improve as we as we
can
our job is to become the most advanced
progressive people ever our job is to
unshackle and unburden ourselves from
these traditions which are all about
oppression and dominance and all of that
no that's not our job anymore our job
now is to do everything we can to
overthrow
the restrictive patriarchal norms of the
past and
in in our addiction to this progress i
think the point we've got to is we've
started to forget some very basic things
about human biology about the need for
human beings you know what we are is
we're communal apes with smartphones
yeah we need the little community that
we have we need to have children and
grandparents and grandchildren all of
these things that actually give our
lives meaning but no we're more
interested in repainting crossings and
transgender rainbow flags or whatever
because that's what we think is the
purpose of our lives
but no notice some where progress is
going right like they always say well
there's progress okay well that sounds
good you know
but to where like if you're going to go
you've got to have a destination and so
what's the destination because you're
exactly as exactly as you're framing it
they they are acting as if our
minds are being imprisoned in our bodies
you know as if our consciousness is
being oppressed by our material self
it's like okay but that's lunacy you
know i mean like i'm i'm not a science
expert but as i understand it the
consciousness is a product of the body
like so you you can't say uh my
consciousness is being generated by my
body it's not being oppressed by my body
no that's not how that works surely you
know that seems to be insane and
therefore justifies you doing anything
to your body in order to appease the
consciousness um
it seems to be back to front you know as
in
you you need to come to terms with what
you are in the world you know your your
you know and everyone like you used to
have to do this you
as you you're young and you sought to be
a particular thing but it turned out you
weren't that particular thing and saying
okay what am i you know what are my
strengths what are my weaknesses you
know you and then you center yourself
and you become accepting of your
position and you
you know become a proper human being
rather than some lunatic on twitter who
has lots of stuff in their bio that
makes no sense so
hey constantin do you love trigonometry
of course incredible interviews
hilarious live streams hard-hitting
satire plus my handsome jawline whatever
takes away from your hairline but if you
do love trigonometry and you want to
support us there's only one place to do
that and that's on locals yes locals is
a brilliant platform that has been
incredibly supportive to our show and
other problematic creators the great
thing about locals is that it's a
community for people who love
trigonometry that's right it's a place
for you to hang out with like-minded
people share thoughts memes and discuss
the show you can enjoy it for free but
it also gives you the option of
supporting us for as little as seven
dollars a month and if you want to give
more you can we have incredible rewards
for our higher tier supporters as well
we've got everything from mugs monthly
group calls and one on two chats with me
and kcat get in join our community by
hitting the link in the description and
the pin comment below see you there guys
carl i'm talking about twitter
not just about twitter but big tech yeah
because
to me you are the one who
started on youtube right when it was in
its nascent phase you gained this huge
following
and then you made the decision before
everyone else
to leave youtube
and strike out on your own
and we talk about big tech censorship
with lots of people we've talked about
it with loads of great people
but people who haven't experienced what
it's like can you explain to us that
journey of starting out and then leaving
why you left because i think this is
really important i wouldn't say that
i've left youtube um because uh load
seats.com does have a youtube channel
which is podcast of the seaters uh you
can you can go find it um we do have a
youtube channel but we don't just have a
youtube channel because it used to be
that uh youtube was
the wild west of the internet you could
literally put anything on there and you
could find anything and
no matter how crazy or normal there was
a huge range and it was very exciting
you know it was a fun place to be
they weren't heavy-handed with their
moderation and then the administrative
state got involved and therefore youtube
were like right okay we're gonna have to
crack down
they now have a very very strict set of
editorial rules um and it became
apparent that if i wanted to be able to
talk about certain things
whether it's an
offensive
take on something or not um why risk it
basically and so we we've started a
website we've got a big team
and we produce lots of good content um
because
that way we can at least be sure that we
have a place to be able to do these
things and you know so people can
subscribe to our website get access to
all the premium stuff we do and
therefore see the things that we want to
talk about that honestly the editorial
standards of the
silicon valley social media platforms
forbid i mean like one example is
twitter and talking about gender binary
you know if you want to question whether
man and woman have any connection to
male or female you could find yourself
getting banned from twitter just for and
i think that's a conversation that's
very much up in the air needs to be
debated and yet one of these platforms
just said nope not at all um questions
about uh covid and vaccines on youtube
are also just verboten you know we
we have had videos struck because we
cited doctors uh people like dr malone
who of course is not on any of these
platforms now the co-inventor of the
mrna vaccine because they
are not
in total lockstep to a particular
narrative and that's quite scary and so
this is why we started it's very scary
man and the thing is like we put a video
of my twitter thread out recently about
why people have accident hasn't doesn't
mention the vaccine at all it's really
talking about the media context the
psychology the psychology of why people
trust the experts a lot less than than
they ever used to and that didn't get
censored outright they just put an
18-only restriction which dampened the
growth of the video for a while and then
they took it off i think jordan peterson
or someone retweeted it yeah so so
there's this we've had uh our video a
video at the beginning of the pandemic
of peter hitchens it was shadow band we
have a video clip on our channel
showing exactly how you couldn't find it
on google and you couldn't find it on
youtube it was shadow band for a few
days
[Music]
there's never any explanation of why
those decisions are made
um
it is very worrying but at the same time
do you think this is a pro is certain
less about the administrative stay but
it's a product of the fact of how big
these companies have become and and the
when you become it's like as we grow
people are like well you've got to think
about this now and you have an audience
so you've got to be responsible about
that like those pressures
are quite natural i'm always very wary
when when you and i know you're not like
this anyway you're not conspiratorial in
this way but i'm wary of people
like they go there's a small there's
like a thing that explains everything
and it's a cabal of small people a small
cabal of people somewhere that are
pulling all the strings do you know what
i mean yeah um i it's not about
conspiracies that's the problem uh if it
was a conspiracy then it would be a lot
easier to expose it and people thought
oh well go good we'll stop doing that
then because the conspirators have been
caught and you know and it's not saying
there aren't conspiracies there are but
this isn't one of them unfortunately
this is to do with the paradigm that
we're in as in the governing principles
of
public life
they put you on a set of rails and the
question is just how far down these
rails are going to go and so if if you
adopt the principle oh well vaccine
misinformation is wrong well then now
we're in control of youtube well we've
got to do something about vaccine
misinformation and so
they can't help themselves and this is
how uh when it was
nadine doris in uh or one of the
conservative uh cabinet members in
parliament i think it was today or
yesterday it is nadine doris it is yeah
yeah who was who's saying that they have
a a
a special squad that monitor the
internet for vaccine misinformation and
remove it because the labour party were
concerned that they didn't well our
disinformation and misinformation unit
is is working and we've done
everything possible i mean i i know that
there have been um
accusations as a strong word but
concerns possibly from the opposition
front bench that the disinformation and
misinformation unit was was no longer in
existence that's not the case it's not
true it is there it is working we did
have a pilot which ran for six months
which stopped but the work from that
pilot now continues with the
misinformation and disinformation unit
and daily that work takes place daily
and daily we work to remove that content
online which is both harmful and
particularly when it comes to coping 19
and vaccinations which is harmful and
provides misinformation and
disinformation
it's like sorry you've got this you've
got this
what like private opaque group in the
government that senses things from the
internet yeah like what are you talking
about okay so that being the case and
look i am broadly on your side
when it comes to this i think we would
yeah exactly get rid of it
[Laughter]
but the problem comes with
what do you do with quite blatant
medical misinformation 5g is cov courses
covered etc etc what do you do with that
does that come within the overton window
do you remove that
what do you do
i think that one of the reasons that
people have less faith in
experts now
is because the experts have essentially
been ignoring the conspiracy theories
and just censoring them yeah and when
you do that that makes people think
right you don't have an answer to this
but you are a tyrant and you are lying
to me and so essentially chris whittie
is going to have to come out and explain
why
5g isn't
whatever the conspiracy is about 5g
they're going to have to explain it and
they might think well this is beneath my
dignity or something
sure but you're dealing with people who
don't know anything about these things
and won't believe you unless you
actually engage properly with what
they're saying and the thing is there
are there are some
kernels of truth in some of these
conspiracy theories that are that when
you censor them what you're saying is
well that's not a kernel of truth the
thing is people have recognized this
with their own eyes they can see that
whatever the kernel of truth the
insanity has been built around they can
see that that is true and so if you deny
that well you're denying
all of it which means it must all be
true you know and so it's
unfortunately requires more interface
from these public experts but they they
hold themselves very aloof i'm not even
gonna dignify that with a response
that's misinformation gone and it's like
sorry that's that's not how you build
trust that's how you build distrust it's
a great point i remember i watched this
documentary on flat earthers
and you know it was quite joking they
were taking the piss are you saying the
earth enough
yeah and
it's hilarious yeah it is it is and they
interviewed this nasa scientist
and she made such a great point she was
like no the reason they believe this is
our fault
it's a scientist's fault because we are
not explaining it in ways that they can
understand and by mocking them and by
censoring all you're doing them is
pushing them into the fringes and the
margins of society instead of welcoming
them welcoming them in and going so
these are your beliefs let me explain to
you in very clear
easy simple to understand ways why why
you what you believe is scientifically
incorrect see it that requires a sort of
level of kindness doesn't it you know a
level of consideration it's not there's
a lunatic who i consider a threat it's
oh there's someone who i can help you
know and look let me because i mean like
the
i
i always had this video that i saw that
was of a balloon that goes up into the
atmosphere and you can literally see the
earth become round right and so i would
send that to flat earthers when i was on
twitter and whatnot because it was just
like well look and then all the videos
okay now everything's fake you know but
you know like but that's exactly the
point then instead of treating them like
a hostile enemy treat them like people
that you're responsible for because
you're the elite you're the experts
you're the people they're looking up to
and you're the people who are losing the
confidence of those people below you so
you have to do something in the way of
outreach if you've got this position of
social responsibility
well that's one of the problems isn't it
because all they're doing by censoring
stuff and not engaging with it and i've
made this you know we had a
controversial scientist on the show very
early in the pandemic who i think said
some things that probably were
completely wrong in my opinion now when
i look back at it but when we went on
rebel wisdom david challenged us on it
and and i made this very point what the
government should be doing is going
here's a video of trigonometry
interviewing dr sachara bhagti and
here's what he says and here are the
facts
and and
and answer people's questions i mean
look at this current vaccine uh
discussion that we're having um you know
that
there are people who are concerned about
myocarditis for example right i think if
you address that issue you would either
explain to people what's going on or
assuage their fears and there's probably
a way to do that for example
yes people are getting myocarditis from
taking the vaccine but it seems that it
doesn't last very long it's not lethal
to the overwhelming majority of people
let's have that discussion instead of
just keeping it under wraps where people
are going well they're not talking about
mike that that means probably everyone
[ __ ] has it well they probably don't
but you need to have the sensible
conversation and and the problem is
we've got the situation now where the
big tech companies are employing a 20
year old in california or a 20 year old
in india to decide what the conversation
that we're allowed to have is what the
truth is look at the lab leak thing
right a year ago wouldn't be allowed to
be discussed now probably is what
happened you know what i mean
notice though that the i think one of
the reasons they don't do this is
because they've got this um
desire for certainty and correctness
under all circumstances like because it
may be that there is a problem with
myocarditis i'm not a doctor i don't
know but if if this is something that's
coming up then they may have to give a
bit on the vaccine narrative which is
the vaccine is perfect and it's flawless
and will save us all and will do no
wrong in any circumstances it's like
well nothing's like that you know that's
an unreasonable standard that you're
setting for yourselves
and then you're censoring things that
might actually
force you to come a bit closer to the
center and say well look okay there are
some problems but overall it's a general
good which i'm sure it is you know but
but by by demanding a standard of
perfection for yourself you are setting
yourself up to be an untrustworthy
narrator on your narrative and that
gives credence to you know people who
i guess rightly we would call fruit
loops you know in crackpots you know and
you make them right by being wrong by
claiming perfection when you don't have
it and it's it's also the way that you
know the people in the public eye
shaming
and using in the language that they use
i take tony blair for example so you
know i'm saying that and people who i
see even i use the language anti-vaxxers
they're not people who haven't taken the
vaccine are stupid and selfish and you
think well how is that going to help
anyone you're not going to persuade
anyone you're just going to drive
someone even further into not taking the
vaccine that's because the reason he's
doing it is not to persuade anyone he
wants to signal to his own side that
he's got the right opinions and that
he's virtuous and he's trying to look
good in public which
that's a bit late for that as i said
before exactly you would not expect from
tony blair but i'll tell you if i was
someone who'd like you know i've been
got my vaccine got my booster and then
tony blair is like yeah those
anti-vaxxers are idiots well god
maybe they've got a point you know tony
blair saying it take this out
but anyway uh carl it's been great
having you back
it's always great to have the
conversation we've got a couple of
questions for our locals only supporters
but before we go as you know i haven't
been on the show many times now our last
question is always the same what's the
one thing we're still not talking about
as a society that we really should be
one thing
um
i actually don't think i can boil it
down to just one thing um but i i think
the general theme of what we've talked
about the the
the abolition of the administrative
state is i think the the main issue to
get out of this problem you know we we
have to get out of the mindset that the
government as you were saying earlier is
the source of all solutions or should be
you know that that that to me seems like
the key issue of the time
you know one thing that just occurred to
me as you said that that actually
i'm trying to think it through but it
seems to me
that a form of
soft authoritarianism best case scenario
is the inevitable consequence of that
thinking because if you think the
government is supposed to do everything
then the government will do everything
and that means that it will control
increasingly large ways of your personal
life and your conduct and your
interactions with other people so
like not doing that
is the only way to preserve freedom
essentially yes absolutely i mean you
we're already in this position you know
we've already been through the log downs
we're already getting to in scotland and
wales with vaccine passports and the
insane contradictory tyrannies that
they're going through let not say what's
going on in the continent or in
australia and in various other places
we're already at that point and
it's going to be very difficult for the
people who have
enforced those kind of regimes to admit
that we made a mistake because then they
have to essentially admit that they're
not heroes they're the villains so
and the problem is though carl is that a
lot of people quite like this
there are there are some yeah i wouldn't
say some
i would say there is a majority it's a
small majority but i think there is a
majority of people how can it be a small
majority because 52 percent
not not 18 yeah but you know when i
don't know if you saw our interview with
stephen hicks about uh yeah
and this is one of the points he made
right at the end which is
a lot of people particularly people who
feel
uh that they're not necessarily well
prepared for life they're not
necessarily able to live their life if
they are the sole person responsible for
their life a collectivist mindset a
mindset of well big daddy government is
going to sort it out and tell people
what to do
is appealing it is a very good criticism
of liberalism to say
that fundamentally you are on your own
that you are an individual you have your
life and you are a free agent you have
the right to life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness now what's
distinctive about liberalism though is
to say that
making your life is a do it yourself
projects not to say that you won't be
very social and other people won't help
you and you'll have wonderful support
networks right and so forth but there is
a bottom line responsibility that
liberalism puts
on each individual
and then we do find a big divide among
among
individuals in a liberal society those
who are
grateful
who are energized who are delighted by
the fact that i am a free agent and i
can do whatever i want with my life and
i'm going to go out and do something
pretty special with it versus those who
feel that as a burden
as a weight
as i'm not sure that i'm up to the task
and that sounds a little bit scary
and for that psychological type i'm just
going to call it a psychological type
right now i do think the collectivisms
are going to be more psychologically
attractive
and it's not just it's appealing as well
it's
i think there are people you know of
around 20 years old now who have known
nothing else you know i can remember a
time i was an adult before all of the
before tony blair well about when tony
blair came into power and so i remember
what it was like before you know
whereas like callum
the host one of the hosts of the podcast
he's 25 he just doesn't remember a
before time that's reassuring to me
because kids always rebel against what
they see well so we may get an ultra
freedom-loving uh generation coming next
i don't know actually i'm i'm not sure
the the statistics on generation zed are
actually in and it's worse than the
millennials good look kill them all
we'll end on that that's a joke youtube
it's just a joke i'm not actually
suggesting violence against anyone
except millennials now uh kyle thanks
for coming back on the show it's been an
absolute pleasure uh thank you all for
watching and listening at home we'll see
you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out 7pm uk time and for those of
you who like your trigonometry on the go
it's also available as a podcast and
before you go i should say carl
obviously low to seaters.com people
should check out your work there yeah
and they can go to uh podcasts and lots
of theaters on youtube they will watch
our daily podcast fantastic thanks so
much we'll see you soon take care and
see you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below